WIL WILLIS: Braxton,
Jake, congratulations.
You fellas have made
it to the third round
of this competition.
Now we're sending
you back to your home
forges just to make this
iconic weapon from history--
the nagamaki.
Good luck, bladesmiths.
We'll see you in four days.
BRAXTON: It's day one.
I'm back at the home forge.
I'm pretty nervous going to
make my first Japanese sword.
The first thing I do is
taking it down to size.
Straightening this
blade is a hassle.
It's wanting to
curve like a banana,
and I'm having to straighten
it out little by little.
I had to be very meticulous
on the amount of curve it has.
It's the start of day two.
And I'm ready to
get to work and try
and get this blade quenched--
fire 'em up, get 'em hot.
I've never welded
anything that big,
and I really just
can't wait to test it.
I can't wait to swing that
thing around in the yard just
to have a feel for how it is.
I check the blade,
and it's hard.
It's straight.
And I just have such
a sense of relief.
Let's hack at something,
see if it's going to break.
Just like that.
It snapped the tip off about
six inches down from the tip.
I will not be able to meet
parameters with this blade,
so I decide to
start a new blade.
Son of a bitch.
You know, I probably
had a stress fracture.
The grain in there
is pretty tight.
I got half a day left to hammer
out and forge out a blade.
BRAXTON: Now that I've
got the blade done,
we got the hibachi done.
And now it's time
to do the tsuba.
The guard is very important.
Everything needs to be smooth.
Ugh, that's a tight fit.
Feels really good.
It's just a little bit heavy.
The nagamaki being too heavy
can make it unwieldable
and make it uncomfortable
to swing around.
That's right where the guard is.
It's a little heavy.
I mill a simple pattern into
the tsuba to lose some weight.
Actually feels a lot better now.
All I lack is the wrapping
and doing a final cleanup.
I only have a few little
things to do on day four.
This is cool.
JACK: My last day I
had so much to do.
I have no room for error.
I was able to forge
out a blade, grind
it out, and get it quenched.
So I'm just going to try
and meet the parameters
and get the blade
turned in and sharp.
That's pretty good.
I have my hibachi done.
That took me a long
time yesterday.
I have my tsuba pretty
much to where I want it.
My main goal for
today in general
is just to get the
handle complete.
I'm quickly running out of time.
I need to make this handle
as quickly and as efficiently
as possible.
I'm trying to get a pretty good
grip on to where the blade is
very easily indexed.
I don't want the
handle to be too thick.
But honestly, I just need
to get a handle on it.
It's solid That's for sure.
Once the glue dries
on the leather wrap,
I go ahead and start this
long process of the ito wrap.
This just so happens to
be one of the hardest
builds I've ever done.
I really could have
used an extra day,
but I'm just happy
that it's over.
Oh, that is smooth!
DOUG MARCAIDA: All
right, bladesmiths.
I will take your
weapons to deliver
killing blows,
slashes, and thrusts
on this wild boar carcass.
Braxton, you're up first.
Are you ready for this?
I'm ready.
[inaudible]
Let's do this.
BRAXTON: Oh, man.
We have a hogs around
where I'm from.
The skin is very, very thick.
I'm nervous, but there
is nothing I can do.
I just gotta let the
chips fall where they lay.
[rock music]
All right, Braxton.
Your nagamaki here is
definitely not boring.
It is razor sharp.
Every cut with this
thick wild boar carcass
allowed me to peel off
layers of the very thick hide
that it has.
Also, the lightness that
you have with this blade
allows for switching
with the grip here.
It's got very good
grip in the handle.
I can index exactly were
the edge is at all times.
Overall, sir, your
nagamaki will kill.
Thank you.
All right, Jake.
It's your turn.
Ready for this?
Chop him up.
Let's do this.
JAKE: It makes me a
little bit nervous.
I really want mine to chop
through the boar as well.
But the blade can actually
take a lot of damage
during the boar testing
because there's bones.
I know that Braxton's
blade set a very high bar.
Mine needs to perform
just as good as his.
[rock music]
DOUG MARCAIDA: All right, Jake.
Let's talk about
your nagamaki here.
It's sharp.
Wielding this weapon
is a lot of fun also.
The weight you have here
and the balance works.
Overall, sir, your
nagamaki will kill.
Thank you.
Next up is the strength test.
Dave?
Now, to test the strength
and overall construction
of your blades, I'll be
chopping into this bamboo.
Now, this test is not about what
your blades do to the bamboo--
what the bamboo
does to your blades.
Braxton, you're up first.
You ready?
I'm ready.
[rock music]
All right, Braxton.
As far as what the bamboo did
to your blade, it did nothing.
There's no deflection, rolls,
chips, anything on this blade.
It's as sharp as
when I picked it up.
Nicely done.
It's a very strong blade.
Thank you so much.
All right, Jake.
You're ready?
Let's do it.
[rock music]
All right.
So your edge, just as
sharp as when it started.
There are no chips,
rolls, defamation.
It sliced right
through the bamboo.
Your handle is a little
wide this way for me.
But the fact that
it's lean this way
and that that wrap's so
nice and comfortable is--
evens it out.
Well done.
JAKE: Thank you.
All right, bladesmiths.
We know your blades can kill.
We know they're strong.
Now it's time to find
out how sharp they are.
Now, unlike the
strength test, this
is all about what
your edge will do
to these different
materials, from the tatami,
the melons, or the sandbags.
Braxton, you're up first.
You ready for this?
I'm ready.
[rock music]
DOUG MARCAIDA: All
right, Braxton.
Your edge had no
issues at all cutting
through the tatami mats.
Cuts the melon easily.
And on the sandbags,
it will cut through.
Overall, sir, your
weapon, it will cut.
Thank you.
DOUG MARCAIDA: Jake, your turn.
Are you ready?
Let's do it.
[rock music]
DOUG MARCAIDA: All right, Jake.
Let's talk about you
nagamaki right here--
razor sharp.
It cuts easily on the tatami.
Cuts the melons.
And just off the orders of
the corners, it cut it easily.
Overall, sir, it will cut.
Thank you.
This is going to
be very hard for us.
WIL WILLIS:
Bladesmiths, the judges
have made their final decision.
The new "Forged in Fire"
champion is Braxton.
Congratulations, you're the
"Forged in Fire" champion.
Jake, unfortunately your
blade didn't make the cut.
Ben Abbott's going
to tell you why.
Well, Jake, you
should be proud.
You made a beautiful
and effective weapon.
And for us this came down
to the finest of points--
the fact that your blade
wasn't quite as finished,
and we had a slight preference
for Braxton's handle.
And that's the reason
we're sending you home.
Jake, please,
surrender your blade.
JAKE: I think the
time frame that I
had to build my second blade
definitely had a factor in it.
I may not be the "Forged
in Fire" champion,
but I feel like I
accomplished a lot
and earned the
privilege to be here.
Braxton, congratulations.
You're the "Forged
in Fire" champion,
and that's a title that comes
with a check for 10 grand.
Good job.
[applause]
BRAXTON: I feel great about
what I've accomplished.
I'm still shaking.
It was an awesome experience,
and I proved that I
can hang with the big guys.
[rock music]